each dot plot below represents a
different set of data we see that here
order the dot plots from largest
standard deviation top to smallest
standard deviation bottom so pause this
video and see if you can do that or at
least if you could rank these from
largest standard deviation to smallest
standard deviation all right now let's
work through this together and I'm doing
this on Khan Academy where I can move
these around to order them but let's
just remind ourselves what the standard
deviation is or how we can perceive it
you could view the standard deviation as
a measure of the typical distance from
each of the data points to the mean so
the largest standard deviation which we
want to put on top would be the one
where typically our data points are
further from the mean and our smallest
standard deviation would be the ones
where it feels like on average our data
points are closer to the mean one all of
these examples our mean looks to be
right in the center right between fifty
and a hundred so right around
seventy-five so it's really about how
spread apart they are from that and if
you look at this first one it has these
two data points one on the left and one
on the right that are pretty far and
then you have these two that are a
little bit closer and then these two
that are inside this one right over here
to get from this top one to this middle
one you essentially are taking this data
point and making it go further and
taking this data point and making it go
further and so this one is going to have
a higher standard deviation than that
one so let me put it just like that
and I just want to make it very clear
keep track of what's the difference
between these two things here you have
this data point and this data point that
was closer in and then if you move it
further that's going to make your
typical distance from the middle more
which is exactly what happened there now
what about this one well this one is two
starting here and then taking this point
and taking this point and moving it
closer and so that would make our
typical distance from the middle from
the mean shorter so this would have the
smallest standard
and this would have the largest let's do
another example so same idea ordered the
dot plots from largest standard
deviation on the top to small a standard
deviation on the bottom pause this video
and see if you can figure that out so
this is interesting because these all
have different means just eyeballing it
the mean for this first one is right
around here the mean for the second one
is right around here at around 10 and
the mean for the third one it looks like
the same mean is this top one and so
pause this videos how would you order
them alright so just eyeballing it these
this middle one right over here your
typical data point seems farthest from
the mean you definitely have if the mean
is here you have these this data point
and this data point that are quite far
from that mean and even this data point
and this data point are at least as far
as any of the data points that we have
in the top of the bottom one so I would
say this has the largest standard
deviation and if I were to compare
between these two if you think about how
you would get the difference between
these two is if you took this data point
and moved it at and you moved it to the
mean and if you took this data point and
you moved it to the mean you would get
this third situation and so this third
situation you have the fewest data
points that are sitting away from the
mean relative to this one and so I
actually like this ordering that this
top one has a largest standard deviation
and this bottom one has the smallest
standard deviation